yes britney spears knows about the free
britney movement and she's saying thank
you
[Applause]
following the court suspension of
britney's father jamie spears as her
conservator last wednesday the pop icon
took to twitter to share this message on
monday
free britney movement i have no words
because of you guys and your constant
resilience in freeing me from my
conservatorship my life is now in that
direction i cried last night for two
hours because my fans are the best and i
know it britney also replied to that
tweet and wrote i feel your heart and
you feel mine that much i know is true
if you had one word to describe how
britney's feeling today what do you
think it is happy britney's new message
echoes what her attorney shared on
wednesday i think the support of the
free brittany movement has been
instrumental
and to the extent that
it allowed my firm to carry the ball
across the finish line i thank them as
well
and you guys know my situation the free
brittany movement first gained traction
in 2019.
long before britney's bombshell
testimony in june of this year factions
of supporters turned out for small
protests like this one what do we want
free britney when do we want it now cut
to 2021 where multiple documentaries and
a media circus have transformed the
movement but their central message
remains the same
[Applause]
and just like the free britney movement
et learned the singer has also felt the
impact of the documentaries about her
case
just because you're in control doesn't
give you the right to treat people
like property
a source told et last month quote
britney is definitely affected by all of
these new documentaries coming out about
her life this is the fight for her life
and she feels really close to winning it
annie and all methods that will help her
move this process along she welcomes it
her own phone in her own private
conversations were used so often to
control her i know for a fact that jamie
would come from brittany and say hey
why did you text this person the
filmmakers behind controlling britney
spears spoke with e.t after jamie's
suspension liz sam
today i mean we were standing out here
and we saw the free brittany crowd erupt
into cheers given the fact that you two
have devoted so much time and energy and
two documentaries to this how do you
feel about today's outcome
um i mean you know brittany has been
asking for this for a long time we know
from the confidential court documents
that we
obtained that at least as early as 2014
she's been talking about
removing her father trying to
communicate it to the court so i think
you know it feels like it's been a
really long time that she's been
communicating this so it was definitely
very moving to be in the crowd when
everyone realized that it happened
allegations made in the latest effects
on hulu dock were a major point of
conversation in the courtroom jamie's
attorneys were questioning the new york
times uh content and that matthew
rosengart was adamantly saying he was
looking into these allegations what was
your reaction when you were hearing some
of that discussion of the work
i was surprised because jamie's lawyer
seemed to refer to it as just a
television show seemingly dismissing the
allegations but we made repeated efforts
to request for comment for them and they
never denied the allegations that they
wiretapped uh britney's bedroom and that
they read her texts with her lawyer
can you tell me about that information
has become so key matthew rosengart was
just talking about it again here now
what was it like for you to i don't know
how you made contact but to first hear
from that former member of the company
that did brittany security and as you're
hearing these allegations
what did you know that you had there
yeah i mean i think we were both totally
shocked he reached out to us and the
first time we talked to him we talked
for 10 hours actually because there was
just so much to talk about
and i think
you know you had heard rumors about
things for a long time but to actually
see someone come forward with evidence
and and of things that seem even more
extreme than than we would have imagined
or the public would have imagined it was
it was a really uh
surprising conversation
[Music]
you